[Music]
hi I'm Pamela today I'm making my
children's favorite Taiwanese people
noodle soup
our dad really loves beef noodle soup as
well too when we you can smell it in the
kitchen it's usually like a homecoming
or someone did good
I think there was one story where our
grandma carried him to get these noodle
soup from Taiwan when she was like in a
sixth grade or something as soon as my
husband and I were baby courageous to
abuse our family from a familiar place
to start a new adventure overseas my
kitchen Institute with the happy and
warm memories we still celebration most
Chinese holidays so we would make it
strongly together in the evening for
Chinese New Year's when we first came to
America 24 years ago the children were
still very young they do not know any
English and I was a skill they knew
English in my cell phone they were
challenging for sure but we learned in
the winter depth and over time it
becomes easier you know I think my mom
was pretty open to having us try like
different foods from supermarkets like I
enjoy when going to shopping with her
just like trying like Lunchables because
that's the thing like that we bring
lunch to school and it's hard to pack
beef noodle soup in the lunch box so I
think my mom was already pretty open
just letting us kind of adapt to you
know the different lunches that you know
we want to try in elementary school I
would bring dumplings to school and it
has a very strong smell so a lot of kids
would kind of make fun of me but now if
I were to bring dumplings to work people
would love it and want to have a piece
so it's something I've grown to be very
proud of
I was inspired at a de-friends a potluck
party someone had a broth beef noodle
soup but I was inspired to try it and
then make my own version I asked my
friend how they make theirs look at the
picture and the recipes and his
tournament and the tribe appearance cut
of meat and the plate with different
ingredients for perfect my recipe that
my family and the bread enjoyed another
tradition that we have is really just
coming home together sitting down for
dinner and talking about each other's
days while my mom is busy running in and
out of the kitchen and we celebrate life
and celebrate each other's companies
when I come home from school or from
work and I see my mom in the kitchen
that's a sense of being home definitely
a comfort feeling you know when my mom
is cooking in the kitchen takes me back
to Taipei or sitting in alleyway that
small streets were crowded next to the
table next to us we're slipping on their
noodles is humid outside but the warmest
soup somehow it makes it that much
better
at least when we were growing up
slurping noodles was not deemed as
inappropriate or ill-mannered in fact it
would signify that this dish is made
really well for me to discard all
manners and just inhaled what is in the
bowl oh yes
[Music]